aménager un territoire à 12 communes en
fonction des problématiques de chacun
c'est le défi de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lancé en 2013
le plan local d'urbanisme intercommunal
pl lui a été dévoilé aux cinq nouvelles
villes entrées en 2016 dans la
communauté d'agglomération on voit bien
que chaque commune à des projets
d'aménagement donc c'est comment on fait
pour les articuler puisqu'un projet
d'aménagement nécessairement des
conséquences sur la vie la côte et en
général en terme de circulation ne
serait-ce que ça donc ça oblige je
dirais les communes à travailler
ensemble pour poser leurs preuves de
leurs projets d'aménagement
on vit pas seul dans son coin il faut
qu'on partage avec avec ce qui ôte toi
coignières les clayes-sous-bois mort pas
plaisir et villepreux ont participé à un
séminaire pour comprendre les enjeux de
ce pays lui quelles zones seront
urbanisés
quels logements seront construits et
quels espaces verts seront préservés
voilà quelques problématiques abordées
les choisit venir à ce séminaire parce
qu'en fait la commune de coignières et
est en cours d'élaboration de son plan
local d'urbanisme est donc être ici ça
permet d'en savoir plus sur les plans
locaux d'urbanisme et à terme les plans
locaux d'urbanisme intercommunaux ce
genre de deux journées permet d'échanger
avec les autres communes pour partager
les expériences pour voir ce qu'on a en
commun ce qu'on a de différent
une cinquantaine d'élus et d'agents des
douze communes de saint quentin en
yvelines étaient présents un premier
séminaire qui pourrait être suivi
d'autres rencontres du même type